two-time NBA champion who also was a
member of the famed Fab five at my alma
mater at Michigan he is Juwan Howard how
are you
coach I'm doing great man I'm doing
great how are you doing better for
talking to you I can't tell you how
happy I am and then to watch the emotion
you had yesterday it was just incredible
walk me through what you were thinking
if you don't mind
coach I don't mind at all and I'm a man
to admit that I did cry like a baby
because of the fact that you know this
is a special moment for me to have a
chance to come back to my alma mater and
coach at a school that I truly enjoyed
and loved they had a big impact on my
life growing up to help meet the mold
mold me into the man I am today
and you know that's going to the
University of Michigan spending time on
this campus getting a chance to meet
people and grow learn how to navigate
your way through life Michigan Teacher
Airy all that stuff and some so when I
reflect back on all that been through to
get to this point where I am today I
couldn't help but to get emotional
because I worked extremely hard prepare
myself for moments like this and now to
have a guy like president mark as well
as Ward Manuel to trust and believe in
me to give me this chance an opportunity
it was just a touching moment well I
mean it's it's not just you know you
preparing for the moment as a coach the
moment in time as well that you're
arriving is remarkable as well where
John Beilein after a very successful run
shocks a bunch of us in the and the fan
base by leaving and then also what you
represent in terms of bringing everybody
together after what happened with the
Fab five it kind of is a row you've got
a lot of responsibility outside of the
X's and O's it seems
Juwan do you feel that you know I
embrace I embrace the responsibilities I
embrace being a leader I embrace
trying to find ways to just help you
know bringing again the gaps of wherever
the holes are to tell help try to fill
those holes you know I've always been
the kind of person that's and I never
looked at it
III we a family and that's something
that this university always represents
as something that I've always learned as
a growing up in a household with my
grandmother and you know mom and dad
being a part of my life could help mold
me into an individual that cared about
people so if that's what we have to you
know find ways to figure out how to
accomplish those goals and seeing where
we can just help build relationships and
keep relationship going I'll definitely
get in the forefront and get on the
front line and try to help to make it
all possible well let's put a pin in I
guess in that part of the conversation I
want to talk about your journey as a
coach and who has influenced you the
most on that front as a coach as a coach
Steve Fisher there's been a hit a big
influence on my life I was also add to
Erik Spoelstra and I've been working for
Erik for last six years learning how to
be a leader learning how to be a game
manager learning how to of course
inspire others with my work ethic also I
learned a lot from him as far as having
that growth mindset I've also had to add
on that list know Pat Riley a guy who I
respect a lot had a ton of success as a
player and also as a coach and general
manager and president in the NBA sitting
there learning from him being like a
sponge and just picking his brain on
things and and my coach the fact that
he's also been a giving person
and helping a young guy like myself I've
had a coach like Jeff Van Gundy who I've
learned a lot from a hard-worker grinder
basketball my basketball genius I've had
a lot of coaches that I've played
or an MEA that I've always gonna be able
to take something from it and use to try
to help you these these young men become
men have you connected with B line as B
line called you okay what was that
conversation like well I reached out to
be line first first I wanted to
congratulate him on getting a job with
the Cleveland Cavaliers we all know
these guys are basketball geniuses too
and he's also a grinder smart man can
develop can teach like no other and also
you know we always seen how everything
blossomed when he touched something so
we talked about in a Michigan we've
always had that relationship where he
knows that you know I've always wanted
to become a better coach so I'll come
here like every summer while b-line was
coaching at Michigan and sit down we'll
just talk basketball we also talked
about life and I've always looked at him
as an advisor but more importantly as a
mentor because he's had so much
basketball experience and head coaching
in E not just on a collegiate level but
also high school so I was always trying
to you know figure out ways to just
learn from him well he's been so super
supportive for this new vent you know
adventure that I'm not adventure excuse
me but new opportunity that I am now now
I've been an embrace man well he's
always been remarkable in bringing in
kids who aren't the so-called 5-star
recruits and holding them and getting
them better from Game one and then
obviously needing them to be as cohesive
and as best they possibly can in the
month of March and hopefully April he
would always do that or are you gonna go
after the five-star recruits that b-line
usually stayed away from you want well
I'm gonna go out to talent in him if
you're 2 star 3 star 4 star 5 star you
know I'm looking and I'm definitely
gonna see you know which are the best
players that would help fit the culture
that Michigan has always had and that
would give us the best chance to not
only win on a court but also continue to
do all the great things
the court to represent the university
like has always been because this this
apply for you know State Michigan the as
you know is it's a beautiful city and
armours a beautiful city
so I would love to have you know if
you're five star come on three star
doesn't matter you know wherever you
that kid does who fits into you know our
system and what we're gonna do and how
we're gonna play and how is that how
will that differ do you think from from
what beeline was putting out on the
floor
beeline did an amazing job of being able
to maximize and develop kids in to a
point where now let's look at it I'm not
sure how many players has been drafted
in NBA and potentially will be drafted
this year because three guys left as we
all know and that there's three guys are
in the draft as we speak
you know Iggy Jordan as well as Charles
which I hope they all three get drafted
and I would like to see all three you
know have much success in the NBA yeah I
mean mo vogner got drafted right here in
Los Angeles and you know very well the
guy who drafted him is it true you did
you interview for the Laker job with Rob
polenka before everything happened with
Michigan John did that happen
yes that's true i I did interview for
the Laker job and we had a good a really
good meeting and I think Rob is just a
phenomenal GM I think he chose the right
man moving forward Frank Vogel's a great
coach I'm sure you're gonna do a great
job there what was it like though
interviewing for your job and your when
your former teammates is on the other
side of the table what was that well it
was a special feeling because you know
spent two years with Rob and you know
watching him at the University of
Michigan and how he operated and knew he
was a smart guy you know in classroom
excelled in the business level when he
worked for a company like CIA I believe
no I saw I'm sorry it was the aren't
tell them mm-hmm yes yes before our soda
to CIA and then from there now to be the
the GM of the Lakers Rob is a
he's a grinder man and he's earned it so
you want out a few more minutes left
with John Howard Michigan head coach on
the Rich Eisen show here and then okay
let's get to the Fab five of it all
you talked yesterday at the at the press
conference about restoring banners
obviously you want to hang one of your
own championship better get totally
understand it restoring the banners that
were taken down from your tenure playing
there is that is that already on the
table with with ward manual in the
school if you discussed that you want
well we haven't discussed that day one
but that's one of the things that we're
definitely going to sit out I talked
about I like to see it happen someday
excuse me I like to see it happen
someday soon I'm sure a lot of us do
there was some great years some years
where you know some not just a fair fire
but all the guys that was a part of that
run contributed and made that day
possible on 92 and 93 honor to the
n-c-double-a championship having a
chance to compete against Duke the first
year I came up short there in the second
year to repeat and go back and play
against North Carolina and lose that
game but that was a lot of hard work
sweat tears put into those years and
then a follow behind that we were one
possession away in 1993 at the Chris
Webber had declared himself for the NBA
Draft and was the number one pick that
year the four of us myself Jalen Jimmy
and Ray went to the lead eight and lost
the Arkansas team that went on and won a
championship but we were one possession
away were going back to the Final Four
again we put in a lot of great years
here at this university and
representatives University like by
champs we had Jalen on in our number one
Juwan and and he he was talking about
how you're hiring makes the peace
between the Fab five and the school that
maybe needed to be made earlier or not
that
that is now history the mere fact that
you have been placed in such a important
role and position at a very important
juncture obviously with B lon leaving
that that that is now done would you
agree with that assessment and it's a
beautiful tie right now and Jaylyn knows
how especially this moment is for me and
my family and you know he know that I'm
gonna do whatever I can to represent
this university to try to continue the
winning tradition and most importantly I
tried to help these relationships be
restored
what about and then I asked him directly
point like blank about within the fab 5
itself just the father you guys have you
spoken to C Webb about color yeah okay
yeah oh yeah C Webb that's my brother
C uh C Webb is uh very active and want
to see this thing happen where I become
the next head basketball coach for the
University of Michigan and he's been
super-supportive from day one and I
he'll be back here supporting me and I
know it I know that it's hard he's
mentioned it well yeah I mean he came on
the show the door's always welcome for
him to come in anytime you want bring
his family everyone they all welcome he
said the day before you were even
interviewed he came on the show and he
pounded the table so hard for you he put
his fist through it so you know I'm just
want to make sure that everybody's cool
him and Jalen are cool and he's Jalen
said that he and C but we'll have a
conversation everyone's need to come
together and hang out and support you
Juwan do you feel like you need to play
a role in that as sitting everyone down
well you know they're men and they hate
that they they will figure it out
together but all aside was to make sure
that it happens because you know it's
the beauty of what we've been through in
life getting back to where young kids
what the impact that we made on college
basketball and how college basketball
how impactful it was for us but we're
doing those experiences and help us grow
together more importantly taught us and
you know so many like you know what
lessons getting out of it was so you
know creative and you know rewarding
that you know wherever is happening and
how older we're getting right now and
all that stuff gotta be put in the past
and we gotta move forward to the future
and enjoy these years enjoy each day
because never know next thing is not
promised yeah I know and so many people
are saying well we do with your new job
can you recruit I mean your first
recruiting job if I'm not mistaken was
the Fab five right John you got everyone
together Jimmy King was my first time
that was your first that was your first
recruiting class was the actual Fab five
from Chicago that you did and then the
second cooling class you know not too
many people know this but I'll say it
right now Maurice Taylor Maceo Basten
Jarrar Ward's write and Lewis Bullock
those four guys you know I can't take
credit for Albert white I can't take
credit for Robert tractor-trailer but
those four are just mentioned I was
hands-on recruiting those guys and then
you know Mac tar enjoy you know Mac
Atari and I was visiting the University
of Michigan it was snowing that day I
mean we had a big snowstorm and his next
visit he was going to visit was UCLA out
there where you are now late and I'm
like yeah how am I going to convince
this guy to come to the University of
Michigan after the next day he's
visiting UCLA it's impossible mm-hmm I
can't create miracles well I guess I did
I'm sorry enjoy silence University of
Michigan it's right that was my brother
for life I love that who was the
difficult the most difficult recruit of
the Fab five for you when you were
fashioning that together best you could
that was difficult one yeah tool and if
you will no it wasn't it wasn't I can't
recall anyone being difficult because
they all was just they understood the
vision they also you know embrace the
fact that winning was important and that
number one priority and so you know if
you don't want to win you know you want
to go out there just go to school and
you
rack up points and stats and make
yourself look good go right ahead but if
you talk about winning n-c-double-a
championships and let's start now with
her let's make something special and
sure enough we've made history
well before I let you go do you want if
you don't mind I've got a suggestion of
what I think is gonna be your toughest
recruit here but I think you can pull
this off okay all righty now hear me out
here you played with him and he he has
gone on Twitter and he has supported you
and he was singing your praises and he
was celebrating you being the head coach
at the University of Michigan but
getting LeBron James under the Michigan
fold mister Ohio State himself would be
just awesome I would love that
if you get LeBron just come and once
twice hanging out talking about Michigan
basketball because he's rooting for you
that would be awesome
it would be awesome but you know what to
me if you say the best Ohio State
there's a strong passion and love for a
holiday you not get that I respect that
totally but one thing that LeBron I have
experienced that Ohio State hasn't
experienced with him is that four
straight championship appearances mm-hmm
and it's during the NBA Finals mm-hmm
two NBA final championship direct the
brat Brotherhood is like no other
and he now understands that and knows
that that you know where my love and
passionate his effort and the respect
that I have for him and his family
hey I'm sure he'll come and I'm take a
visit and do you see how special this
place here is of course we're love to
get LeBron now you know I can't you know
I don't want to like be kind of turns I
don't want and to dub later you know say
I'm recruiting anyone no but later
LeBron but John I'm not gonna get you in
trouble on day one I refuse to do
Bron James to come watch a Michigan
practice that's all I'm saying
just get I'm just I don't know if that's
I don't think that's a violation of
anything he wants to come and hang out
and just just put a just put a Michigan
hat on him just want just something snap
a picture let's put it out there that
would be that's that could be your first
win before even play a game you want
that's what I'm saying and and I guess
that's that is also just to finish up I
guess that's the the headline of this
whole thing anything's possible you are
the head coach of Michigan basketball
and speaking on behalf of all the alums
that I know and myself I think it's just
awesome and go crush it go blue man rich
I love you brother
thanks thank you for everything man
thank you for the support absolutely and
happy for life gold blue baby you got it
just let me know that's Juwan Howard
Michigan head coach here for more of the
Rich Eisen show tune - audience Channel
239 on Direct TV for free on BR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app